man it says here you were born in 1908
that makes you 45 years old that's right
Adaline Marie Bowman was born on January
1st 1908 many years later she would
begin a family of her own on a cold
winter night in 1935
Madeline's life would change forever
in that moment something incredible
happened its effect was almost magical
Adaline Bowman will henceforth be immune
to the ravages of time she will never
age another day
like to ask you a few questions miss
Palmer the next time we see each other
I'll have a new identity
I'll always be your brother you know
always be my daughter happy birthday
brother
exactly like this old friend line we
were very close
don't you miss having something to love
it's not the same when there's no
growing old together without that love
is just heartbreak
I'm Alice pleasure to meet you I'll just
wait with you
thank you I'll manage
wait how do we get in touch first time I
saw you they never had to meet you I
didn't know when or how but I knew I
I was responsible and these years it's
lived
I just never has a life I don't know
tell me something I can hold on to
forever I really like oh my god
been running for so long I don't know
how to stop